Kathleen goonie works for the French
General Confederation of labor union
which is trying to stop the kind of
labor market reforms Germany has already
introduced she wants to keep Frances
35-hour week and strict employment
protection laws the key personnel
municipal don't know where the Germans
accepted reforms like this people in
France are protesting against them we
don't want to lose the social gains
we've made dizzy kisses fuel converter
thing we want to hold on to rights that
have been in place since 1936 yeah you
changing the law would result in the
employees losing the advantage they hold
now opposition to the reforms is bitter
even though the French unemployment rate
is twice as high as it is in Germany the
new laws would curtail the union's
influence so the left-leaning cgt is
also in the midst of a power struggle
refinery workers are striking hitting
the country where it hurts the
government has had to tap strategic
reserves to keep vehicles out on the
road in the North French motorists are
crossing the German border filling
stations in the city of saw broken are
only too happy to have the extra
business but many German business people
are shaking their heads of the French
Union reaction august wilhelm share for
example is holding back on investing in
france partly because of the inflexible
labor market laws there he says reforms
are long overdue when you see qualified
people locked out of their professions
you know something is wrong with the
structures it's important to realize
that there are no god-given structures
you have to keep adapting to the current
situation in economic situations and
technological developments and not be
stubborn like a three-year-old who wants
everything to stay just the way it
always has been life is Bashar MOBA ends
up working where thousands of Germans
and French crossed the border daily the
strike is a hot topic
even in the shoe stores salesman Kido
Feldon grew up in France he sympathizes
with French people who say they're
fighting for their rights can be the
root penny I understand this rage I can
relate to it it's not my approach I'm
not the rebellious type but I can
understand the motives candy candy candy
them would you bet your first that's
part of the cliche about the French it's
good isn't there quicker to take to the
barricades than Germans oily prefer to
negotiate if I donkey what rights should
workers have how flexible should they be
required to be and how many hours should
people have to work these women have
different opinions on the strike popeyes
I can't get any worse than it already is
we have to open our mouths and do
something about it before they and walk
would good you should enter their food
as feet of kids I go for the 40-hour
workweek again that would be better
political economist oliva goal from the
supporting chamber of commerce and
industry has been watching developments
in France partly for the sake of German
companies businesses in the two
countries are closely intertwined it
signers of yours it's a symbiosis a
competition everything and when the
French are doing badly we suffer so our
companies have a great interest in
seeing the French do well then they
order more and pay more the union
activist Kathleen Guney intends to keep
demonstrating until the government
reverses its reforms and puts things
back as they were don't know Mom Kalama
qui RT shall our dissatisfaction the
government says we're in the minority
but it's the majority that's responding
and taking to the streets in the final
days before the European soccer
championship there's still no agreement
in sight
you